[Applause]
welcome to swipe from a brew house this
week and it's a special one the first of
its kind in the UK I'm told we're gonna
be talking to pet pitbulls in just a few
minutes and here's what else is coming
up to you on this week's show Thomas
gets hands-on with robotics to boost the
next generation with his head turns and
Tammuz getting nostalgic with a major
new release and a classic franchise
that's also come for you after a quick
look at some of the tech news headlines
that grabbed our attention this week we
saw billionaire entrepreneur Elon Musk
promoting his latest venture
flamethrowers this week according to us
his company sold out at $500 blow torch
light products within days but even his
promise to ship all flamethrowers with a
complimentary fire extinguisher is
unlikely to appease anyone concerned
about safety officials in the US are
investigating whether Apple misled
investors by not telling them about a
software update that slowed down older
iPhones the tech firm is facing a wave
of lawsuits surrounding the issue apple
says the update was designed to stop
devices abruptly shutting down due to
low battery Renault has been showing us
what it would be like to travel in its
new concept car the symbiosis de Meaux
car is electric and autonomous so a
driver can use the journey time to do
other things like slip on a virtual
reality headset and pretend they're
somewhere else for example you know
those fears about robots taking our jobs
check out Japan's first robot cafe with
a robot barista named soya he or she can
apparently serve up to five cups of
coffee at a time the manager says having
fewer human staff members means they can
increase productivity and serve coffee
at a reasonable price we'll be getting a
look around
there was no beer for Thomas and right
he went to find out how one British
company is helping raise the next
generation of odors and robot creators
as markets move classrooms must change
to train a generation of kids in the
skills of the future that's the goal of
Colchester based firm rapid education
they've partnered with vex robotics to
bring the latest in high-end learning
tools to schools the v5 was just
released and announced about two weeks
ago this is our UK unveil here it's our
really excited to bring this new
technology into the classroom this
allows us to bring some of the new high
end technology concepts like full-color
touch screens like smartphones and
vision tracking systems like smart cars
and autonomous vehicles and that's when
it takes out my terrible driving exactly
it can improve that just a little bit as
the curriculum evolves to include more
advanced STEM subjects that is science
technology engineering and mathematics
robotics and coding are starting to play
a very big role
the robots provided here cater for all
levels of learning from seven year olds
in Key Stage two right up to university
level training the new v5 system aims to
make that learning and teaching
experience more accessible with
smartphones style screens offering new
color detection technology
it's not just in the classroom that this
technology has been used is it you're
also you also run competitions
absolutely there's about 20,000 teams
across 40 countries that compete in new
games that are released every year rapid
are also getting kids hands on with
everyone's favorite gadgets we got into
drones really because we were looking
for a project that was very design led a
lot of schools have 3d printers and
they're looking at manufacturing as a
process but finding a really good
project to attach 3d printing as a
process to was very difficult what that
allowed us to do was provide simple
electronics to the students and get them
to think about the design of the drone
itself how do I go about making a drone
frame what elements do I need to
consider is its strength is it weight is
it flexibility there's a new wave of
graduates into the workforce they will
do so with a set of skills unimaginable
when I was at school now so what is a
tech show like Smart doing in a
bereavement it'll make sense once you
hear about the 2.5 million pounds
cutting edge system they've got here at
in London this is the brew house it's
been said that beer came before bread
but I wonder what ancient Brewers would
have made of the high-tech shiny new
brewing system that's apparently
increased this company's output by 400%
we have four vessels a mash tun a louder
ton a kettle and a whirlpool every
process that we used to do manually that
we used to we used to have to climb into
vessels with a shovel to empty them out
that's automated now we used to have two
control valves by hand just sort of
mixed temperatures and that's automated
now everything that we want control over
we have that control is this now live
inside the vessel yeah so everything
that we saw upstairs is represented on
the screen here here's where much of
that control is centered real-time
information for each vessel with volumes
brushes temperatures and flow rates I
can you know open a valve by touching it
on the screen I can turn on a pump I can
do anything that I want in the old days
we used to have to you know climb up on
top of vessels and open and close valves
ourselves and when you say old like a
month ago the actual brewing time on
average of around four weeks from grain
to can hasn't changed since the new
system arrived but the brew house says
it's producing four times the amount of
beer that it used to wear we can't all
our beer we do about 12,000 cans per
hour
yeah fully automated state-of-the-art
most referees would be canning their
beer at maybe a quarter this vid the new
brewing technology also means the
company can create new flavors doctor
slow you have it all the way you don't
sadly though there's no tech on site to
help perfect the art of pouring a pint
we don't want to encourage an unhappy
life but after bringing you beer we're
now gonna bring you video games
tamal has been reviewing his pick of the
latest releases the first big release of
2018 is Street by a 5 arcade edition 3
fire 5 was actually released in 2016 it
was a missing a few key features that
would have made it fun for everyone and
those are here in Street Fighter 5
Arcade Edition the big new edition is
actually arcade mode which channels
nostalgia it's like the classics you
remember like Street Fighter 2 in which
you fight a series of opponents and then
end with vas-y and get a cool ending
except this time they're really leaning
hard into noir stylized 30th anniversary
of the series so they're going back and
making everything look like Street
Fighter 2 is 3 5 3 Street Fighter Alpha
and a few other classics that you might
remember all the characters that have
been released since through fire 5
originally launched is going to be
included in the version that you buy of
Arcade Edition if you already own it you
get as a free upgrade
so three fire 5 Arcade Edition is the
full rounded experience it's got plenty
bang for your buck and it's a game that
anyone can pick up and anyone can have
fun with
I wouldn't put money on your chances of
walking out of
in Episode four of Batman the enemy
within the Joker finally arrives in
Gotham except he's always kind of been
there usually me him as John Doe in
Arkham Asylum and over time you
establish a friendship with him Bruce
Wayne and Batman work alongside this
character using him for information and
helping him complete missions however
these games are all about choice and
consequence and in Episode four you were
forced to face what happens when you
mistreat a character who's on the edge
whether you've treated him poorly or
whether you've been kind to him impacts
the kind of characters that he becomes
in the future on the one hand you may
get a character who shows sympathy and
shows empathy towards other people
however on the other you may get the
stone-cold Joker that we all know and
love episode 4 of Batman the enemy
within is compelling and as it's the
penultimate episode it sets the stage
for a thrilling finale
final game I'm going to be talking about
is Shadow of the Colossus for
PlayStation 4 it's one of the greatest
games of all time so if you haven't
already played it you've definitely to
check it out you players wander who
travels to a weird far-off land
alongside his trusty steed Al Groh there
he's hoping to find and kill a series of
colossi and in doing so bring back a
loved one this is one of the greatest
games of all time for a number of
reasons it's gotten incredibly
foreboding somber atmosphere it's got
these majestic creatures and in 2018 it
looks better than ever
it's only have gone back and rebuilt the
game from scratch but importantly
they've not touched the finite details
of it so it actually feels more like
restoring a classical painting this is a
must play for anyone that has a
PlayStation 4 well that's it for this
week's show
join us again for more swype next week
and in the meantime follow us on Twitter
sky news flight bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]